and we are live welcome everybody to
another YouTube hangout super excited to
be back on with you I love Thursdays get
to do all these interviews so much fun I
have a repeat guest with me you may have
remembered my special guest Phoebe when
we talked I don't I want to say two
weeks ago about yeah the brand
journalism advantage I was interviewing
her on my channel and now she wanted to
interview me for her podcast and today
we're gonna talk about how to have
success with YouTube for all you guys
that they're wanting to have more
success on YouTube so Phoebe welcome
back hey thanks for having me so good to
be here
cool so Phoebe's gonna run this like her
podcast so I'm gonna turn over the reins
to her and she's gonna go to her intro
and whatever magic stuff she does you
guys can check out the brand journalism
advantage it's the brand journalism at
Vantage comm is that where people yes
that's right or even easier than typing
that as think like a journalist comm
they both direct they're so cool pretty
easy to get there and right I've got the
rain so let's go right get me up here we
go well you know this is really cool
brand journalism community because we're
doing something a little bit different
and I really want to direct you to Evan
Carmichael comm to check out his YouTube
channel and learn about what he's doing
for entrepreneurs because you guys come
to my show to learn a lot of information
about brand journalism storytelling
entrepreneurship and this goes
hand-in-hand so so fun I was on Evans
show a little while back at the time of
this recording and now Evans joining us
and we're doing it as a Google hangout
so Evan is really testing me here and
and pushing me to move into that space
of video having come from the world of
TV I really need to do more of that so
Thank You Evan for getting me here but
welcome brand journalism community I am
phoebe Joan Chua thanks for tuning in to
the brand journalism advantage podcast
here we go with the inside scoop on
today's show Evan Carmichael Evan
believes in entrepreneurs at the age of
19 he built then sold a biotech software
company now at just 22 years old he was
a VC helping five hoping to raise five
hundred thousand to fifteen mil
today he runs Evan Carmichael dot-com a
popular website which is loaded with
information for entrepreneurs he
breathes and bleeds entrepreneurship he
is obsessed with it and aims to help 1
billion entrepreneurs change the world
welcome to the show Evan how are you
having me on pumped I'm ready to do this
yeah me too me too well we share a word
in common as we were discussing before
we got online and that's believe I want
you to quickly tell me how that word
came about to you why is it so impactful
yeah and so I believe everybody has one
word that defines them it's actually the
topic of of my new book I think most
people aren't aware of what their main
core values are and as a result they
kind of live life not as purposefully as
it could be and so for me I was running
the business I was having some success
but I felt kind of disconnected I felt
like I could be having a greater impact
I felt like I could do more and I think
a lot of people feel that like I'm doing
ok but I feel like there's more to me I
feel like I'm not reaching my potential
and so I started looking inward to
figure out what is it that I'm all about
before getting to what project I'm gonna
work on like who is Evan Carmichael what
do I stand for you know what's the most
important core value to me and it kept
coming back to this word believe and I
ended up doing this crazy thing and
build my entire business around believe
and everything that I've touched that
had to do with believe just instantly
started doing well and taking off and
you know we can go further into all that
if you want but I think kind of
understanding your core value what
you're all about and then bringing that
to your business and your life so
everything is done a lot more on purpose
will make you happier as well as have a
much greater impact on the people around
you well you know brand journalism
community we talked about positivity we
talked about storytelling and belief is
certainly at the core when you want to
launch a brand or a business if you
don't have that the chances of
succeeding are very very slim I've often
referred to my career in TV and the fact
that I was able to get into the San
Diego marketplace at 19 I had to really
believe so great great word what we're
talking about in this episode brand
journalists
community is building your internet TV
channel and I love this because Evans
done a remarkable job at it so make sure
you go to his site you'll find them in
the show notes that think like a
journalist comm and check it out you'll
see I mean it's literally like turning
on a great cable channel and and just
watching I mean you know I do it all the
time with your stuff so good good stuff
but before we go into those top tips
let's kick it off with your icebreaker
and Evan you know this just doesn't
surprise me in light of what I read in
your bio but at 5 years old
get this Evan was convincing his yes
three-year-old little sister to go into
business with him essentially was it art
and baseball cards tell me yeah so yeah
my first thing was selling art I was
five my sister was three and I convinced
her to just draw we went to our bedroom
we were drawing stuff on paper and then
I wanted to go door-to-door in my
neighborhood and sell them and I sold my
first piece to my next-door neighbor for
five cents or ten cents and yeah I was
in business that was my first adventure
well that's cool because I got to tell
you my older sister she didn't sell her
artwork she sold my mom's jewelry and
let me tell you that didn't go over too
little entrepreneurs running around all
right well you know we kick it off with
the think like a journalist quote and I
know this is gonna resonate with you but
I'd love to get your input the true
entrepreneur is a doer not a dreamer
Nolan Bushnell entrepreneur what do you
think of that I love that yeah I think a
lot of I think I think a lot of
entrepreneurs are dreamers too but I
think the ones that make it or when they
can combine it because everybody has
some kind of dream even people who are
in a company there's a lot of people
thought about wanting to start their own
business and they don't yeah and the
biggest thing that separates someone who
has a lot of success as an entrepreneur
from the ones who don't is that they
actually did something about it
they don't just dream about it don't
just complain when somebody else gets
takes your idea and makes sense of money
off of it they had the courage to get up
and take action and it's not about being
a type-a personality or
introvert/extrovert are tons of
resources and no resources people
successful entrepreneurs come from all
walks of life but the one thing that
they all had in common is that they got
started and took action so it's a must
to be a successes entrepreneur for sure
well share with us a success tip or a
quote we know that your one word is
believed but what's something that'll be
impactful as people want to build out
maybe their own internet channels maybe
there's a code or a tip that you'd like
to share around that or one that's just
meaningful to you um one of my favorite
quotes comes from Calvin Coolidge and
it's actually on the desk kind of behind
me back there where he says persistence
alone is omnipotent and that's maybe a
mouthful and not easily kind of
understood by everybody but he's
basically going on and Calvin Coolidge
was the president United States do a lot
of people don't know that either
but basically saying it's not about how
wise you are it's not about how many
resources you have it's not about most
of the things people think make up
success its persistence it's just
getting up and doing it again and doing
it again and do it again and when you
have a dream and you want to do
something that hasn't been done before
especially there's gonna be people who
hate art there's gonna be people who
tell you can't do it you're gonna tell
yourself sometimes that you can't do it
that you're crazy and what am i doing I
should go back into the safe thing and
the thing that just keeps you going is
that persistence the the persistence
will solve the problems of humanity just
keep on attacking it until you climb
that mountain that's right never never
giving up well it certainly sounds like
you have that thriving spirit from all
of what we've heard but what I'd like
you to do is take us back in time let us
get to know you a little bit more with a
little bit more of your backstory and
then take us forward to that moment in
time that is considered your proudest
moment your career highlight okay so how
far back do you want to go you know fill
in a little bit of the gaps where we
talked about you know you were 19 you
built this business I'm kind of curious
how you know I
19 would you build and sell a biotech
software and then don't forget to take
me to that moment that one moment one
story that's your proudest moment sure
um I think I had a lot of
entrepreneurial tendencies growing up I
didn't really recognize them nobody in
my family was entrepreneurs my parents
had safe kind of jobs they supported
everything I did they supported my
baseball card ventures and my you know
lemonade stains and when I tried to turn
raisins into grapes outside and try to
sell them and didn't realize it goes the
other way I still thought I wanted to be
a banker in my high school yearbook when
I was graduating this says we're gonna
be in ten years from you was VP at a
bank so I had a lot of tendencies but I
didn't I didn't have the environment
around me to kind of push me to be an
entrepreneur I connected with two people
in my university and they had a software
company that I joined as an owner in and
that was my first real exposure to
entrepreneurship and I was faced with a
really really really tough decision as
to whether I should go I had
opportunities to go work for the banks
that I thought I wanted to do and make
you know 80 hundred thousand dollars
starting salary and fire in the world
and all of these great things that I
thought I wanted versus be at this
startup where I was not making anything
$300 a month and that was one of the
toughest decisions of my life
was deciding I'm gonna I don't wanna
live with regret I want to I'm gonna try
this and give myself a year and just see
how it goes I could live with turning
the jobs down and come back next year
and get a different job me I'd be that
exact same job but I can find another
job where I felt like this opportunity
isn't gonna come around again and I owed
it to myself to to try and that's one of
the proudest moments of my early career
I think because I've used that framework
that decision making process for every
big decisions I've had to do in my life
will I regret not doing this mm-hmm and
if I'm gonna regret it then I have to do
it even if I'm afraid if I'm scared if I
don't have the resources even if
whatever reason comes into your head
when you're
rate or something if I'm going to regret
not doing this then I have to go and do
it and that time the first time making
that decision was so hard looking back
now it's so easy to say oh I was like
the easiest decision ever like of course
it made sense but it was it was
massively painful and ever since then
it's been a lot easier to make those
tough decisions because I just fast
forward to life at 90 or you know by the
time I'm there might be like we're
living forever so I'll be like you know
250 looking back to my my years and just
not living a life full of regret it's
really helped me make a lot of important
decisions I think a lot of people
listening to that when they hear not
living with regret you know they
immediately might feel that that twinge
of pain or something because they go oh
I regret this so I think the message is
if you're living in that space now you
know hearing what Evans saying you have
to move beyond that because the real
risk is living with it right living with
that regret of something I know was a
burning desire and I wanted to do for me
it was that newscaster I was scared to
death
to talk you know to a microphone or a
camera I mean you know so so how do you
become a newscaster then so I I know
exactly what you're talking about every
night I'd like for you to share with us
a time you know because this goes hand
in hand it makes people understand and
helps them you know move to that space
where they're not going to live with
regret that there are going to be
mistakes there are gonna be those
moments in time and I call them when it
didn't work so share with us a story now
about when it didn't work what was your
struggle and really on pocket take us to
that moment so we can feel what you are
experiencing and then tell us how maybe
you found correction as direction
through that one it didn't work moment
correction is direction I like that like
that yeah so especially in that first
company I'll take you to one of the
hardest days ever in my life
I was sitting there with my business we
were not having success I'm making a few
hundred dollars a month I'm lying to my
friends saying that I can't go out to
dinner or whatever with them because I'm
busy in living the entrepreneur dream
and all
I just really couldn't afford it and I
didn't I was too ashamed to tell them
I'm the kind of guy who I worked hard at
everything I did and I knew when I
worked hard I got results in school and
in athletics and whatever I did and here
I was I was working I was grinding like
every waking hour was going to this
business and I was not getting results
and I just felt absolutely worthless
like I'm adding no value to the world
and it's just with with months and
months and months of this happening it
just takes its toll on you and you feel
like a total failure and it was and I'm
wasn't used to feeling that way
so that a family dinner and I remember
having a disagreement with my partner
over what the direction of the company
should be and I I just I told them you
know what I'm tired of feeling useless I
quit I'm out I'm like I'm done you do
whatever you want to do and I help the
phone and just started bawling you know
stuff come out of my nose my eyes like
just terrible and my mom comes up it was
it was Thanksgiving or something she
hears me she was her hand on my shoulder
and I don't even know what she says and
just like that's the lowest point ever
in my life and what I learned from that
the correction is direction I had a
terrible night's sleep and I woke up the
next day I realized like I don't want to
be a quitter like hearing those words
come out of my mouth just didn't feel
right and I still had passion for this
alliance was I just have to find a
different way to stand I have to find a
different way to do this and going to
rock bottom helped me realize that you
know what I'm not the first guy to try
to sell software before you know if
somebody's figured this out why do I
have to come with every genius idea
myself
somebody's figured this out I need to
learn from that and apply it to my
business and so I looked up Microsoft
and Bill Gates and how Bill Gates
started zero to one that's it not how he
makes another million now it's like who
cares zero to one how did he get there
and it was through partnerships and so
that strategy I applied to my business
and that's actually how I started to get
out of the hole but coming down to the
bottom the corrections Direction moment
for me was
realizing that I'm not the first guy to
try to do this somebody has figured it
out and I can learn from it tweak it and
apply it to make it work for me wow what
a cool story but you know we don't we
don't grow like that I don't think
anyway until you hit those moments we've
all had those really deep dark moments
when we feel some level of shame and
just being able to push through that
shows your character and like we talked
about at the very beginning that
entrepreneurial spirit of perseverance
right and the taking action 100% and a
big credit goes to my business partner
to where you know I quit on him I said
no you know I'm out and then the next
day I woke up and I like I wanted to
keep going and I just showed up at his
apartment like I normally I work from
his dining room table out of his condo
that was our headquarters and I should
have the next day and and he didn't even
like we had no conversation I just
looked him in the eyes and like went
back to work and he's gonna give me a
really hard time yeah right like he
could have said I thought you quit man
you're out like you could have had a big
ego trip and so to his credit to I was
able to just go back to work and we
eventually found their way out out of
that massive hole yeah we're stay my
life oh man I I can imagine but you know
there have been so many better days so
that's cool thanks for sharing that
let's dive into this building your
internet TV channel Evan because I mean
alright so you came from that you were
19 you did some other things neros VC
but then you got this idea so take me
back to when the idea came about to do
the channel and then give us an an idea
of like you know did you just say
hey everybody's watching YouTube I want
to be there what what happened yeah so
when I started YouTube I didn't want to
be YouTube famous like it wasn't a thing
YouTube celebrity was not the aspiration
I think a lot of people now are like I
want to be I want to be rooting for us
my career I never thought I would make
money from YouTube it wasn't my goal I I
found a lot of success in modeling
others so Bill Gates saved my business
even though I never met him because of
how he started Microsoft and there
a lot of great resources that I found
online in a visual format I like I like
learning visually through a lot of books
and stuff but I wanted a visual format
so I started making videos on YouTube of
successful entrepreneurs and how they
got started fortunately for myself to
keep learning from these great
entrepreneurs and also to share it in
hopes that other people wouldn't have to
feel the Biglow that I felt when I was
starting my company so I did a bunch of
those and then people started asking me
questions and I would write out long
email responses I would take 20-30
minutes and I thought why don't I just
turn this into a video I'd rather talk
then right and it'll help them and it'll
help other people have the same problem
and so I started making video responses
out of that and started building up I
guess expertise there was no strategy
though it wasn't like this was not part
of my plan I think now if you're looking
at getting online and building a brand
and being seen as an expert or being a
reporter or a journalist I think it's
it's a critical component but when I was
starting out it was just curiosity I
wish I could say like I knew it I had it
all planned that I'm a genius but it was
all like just fumbling my way through
all right so let's talk a little bit
about it somebody who's listening and
you know because I always encourage
brands on this podcast the brand
journalism advantage to be the media and
what I mean by that is exactly what
you're doing
you know you intentionally are not
intentionally you luckily wound up that
way and so you get great interviews so
let's let's talk about going back in
time you had this idea you started doing
it you started learning from it but now
you know 20/20 hindsight right so what
would you tell our audience listening
today what are the first steps of doing
it obviously taking action setting up
your video and not being afraid to get
on we hear a lot of that but what are
some of the strategic strategies that
you can you know to share with us to
build it because now when people watch
or when they're starting to do this
there's so much noise and so much
disruption how do you get through and
find that audience so first off I would
say there's always room for
quality in whatever industry you're in a
lot of industries are noisy there's
always room for quality at the top so
you have to make something good if you
make something good you'll be able to
gain an audience I would say understand
what it is that you want to like what
are you staying for what's your message
like if you're reporting on the news and
you report it the same way everybody
else is reporting it you're gonna lose
you need your own your own style your
own edge your own one word your own like
Phoebe doesn't do it the way everybody
else does it you know you need your own
Phoebe recipe your own special sauce has
to come out in your delivery of the
content I think it gives you a lot more
freedom to have it on your own channel
where if you're in a news program you're
expected to be formal and you'll say
these exact words and don't deviate from
the script and these are how anchors you
know are supposed to act where it
doesn't allow for a lot of personality
to come out where with your own show you
could do whatever you want you know and
so I think that's super important I
would I would expect to suck at the
start now if your audience are already
journalists already has some kind of
on-camera experience they might be ahead
of the game to break the most people but
expect expect to suck like expect your
first thing not to do well I think a lot
of times we put so much pressure on it
on ourselves that the first thing has to
be great it's like going on a first date
with somebody and expecting to marry
them you put so much pressure that it
then it doesn't work out like the first
time you get on a snowboard and you're
going down a hill you're gonna fall down
100 times right that's just it's okay
and I think people look to the bigger
youtubers and they say well look at how
that person is delivering looking look
at how you know Greg Phoebe is at her
podcast I want to do it like her and you
get on it you do your first podcast and
it's nowhere near but you can't compare
where you're starting with where
Phoebe's at now because of all the
experience that she said and I so I
think it's important that the quantity
leads to the quality but you got to do a
lot of work I'm not gifted at this I
have 4,000 plus videos of experience and
if you go back to my channel look at me
early days it's
Bera Singh I watched like oh man no it's
all good and that that sounds like my
early news casting days embarrassing
thankfully YouTube wasn't around then so
not archived to the web well can you
give us maybe three things and I'm
talking about in building the channel
obviously you know you want quality over
quantity but there is that pressure
because if your if your quality means
releasing one video once every three
months you know you're not gonna build
that audience you have to be more
consistent think about TV news you got
to be able to turn it on and and and
have it there so what are three things
that you learned through this process
that helps you build your channel and
that could be you know whether you were
using Instagram or Pinterest or buying
ads via YouTube but what are the three
things that you think really helped you
first that I've had the most success
within the platform so I haven't had
success by promoting it on Twitter or
Facebook or Instagram or going off
platform to promote it but most of my
success within platform organic or were
you doing paid you know did you build
eventually into paid like paid doesn't
give you subscribers paid doesn't give
you the long term success paid well like
if you want vanity metrics and you want
to say hey I have X number of views and
that helps you go get corporate
sponsorship or whatever then you can do
it but it's not going to lead to real
engagement so it's a model especially if
there's like if you had some sponsored
content that you really want to drive
use up on you know you could put a paid
program behind it they get some exposure
and most brands they don't even know
what they're doing on YouTube so all
they care about is the views and so you
can you know inflate your numbers but
it's not going to help your channel
really in the long term it's like the
vanity metrics on any of these things
you know if you have a Twitter feed that
has tons and tons and tons of people but
and they're not quality people and
they're not engaging what's the point so
okay so you did it organic and and two
other things and you did it within the
platform that
interesting yeah I would say create
content that you want to see that you
feel is missing so a lot of the stuff
that I've done I was the first to do it
because I didn't even want to do it I
wish somebody else had done it I wanted
to just be a consumer of it but it
wasn't being done and so I went out and
had to do it and now build a team around
there's six people full-time working on
my youtube channel I had to go out and
make it and so like where's the hole in
the market if you're a journalist
reporting on something what what's the
problem with journalism that you see
today and how can you fix that problem
for yourself and bring it out and then
if I had to give another tip I would say
I saw really big jump when I moved to
daily content instead of weekly moving
the daily content I think one within
just a youtube algorithm they like
seeing more content coming out and as
people watch one video they want to see
what else you have and they watch the
next video in the next video in the next
video and I think also it just helped me
get a lot better in that the more videos
I did the more comfortable I got the
more expressive I became the more my
nature came out the more I kind of
figured out what I was all about and so
jumping from like 1 to 2 to 3 videos a
day like now we're up to five to nine
videos a day on the channel but the
biggest jump I think came from once a
week to once a day yeah and so I would
encourage like yes quality is important
absolutely if your stuff is garbage it
doesn't matter if you're posting 20
times a day it's not gonna help you but
understanding that the quantity leads to
the quality you're gonna suck at the
start and you have to put in the work to
get good at it and don't be so
embarrassed because nobody's watching
you to start anyway so when you're have
all of these crappy videos you know
nobody's watching you so get out there
practice that's right
definitely all right it's time to think
like a journalist Evan you've been hired
to help an ailing company it's about to
financially collapse now its reputation
shot
you've got a month $1,000 budget a
smartphone and a laptop
how do you begin to turn this company
around I would look at what strengths
the CEO ideally founder of the business
has and I would I would leverage that
you don't really need money to do it I
don't even need a thousand dollars to do
it I would ideally try to get the story
out on a video format because people
connect with video better but what I
would want to see is the passion and
conviction of the founder telling the
story as to why he or she started the
business why they're at where they're at
now and how they're gonna come out of it
and it doesn't have to be highly
produced it could be off your cell phone
you know if I had a thousand dollars I
would I would just buy it you know a
five or ten dollar like tripod stand for
that cell phone so it's not like wobbly
as I'm going through it maybe even a
external microphone jack but you don't
really need that and I would want to
start storytelling around the founder as
to why you're here and the passion to
want to come through I need to feel if
I'm if I'm a consumer if I'm a like if
it's a public company if I'm
shareholders if it's the media I want to
feel a personal connection to the
founder and the story that's behind it
and the confidence that you're gonna get
through it what is one piece of
technology video multimedia equipment or
an app that you just can't live without
I like I can't live without you too but
it's more a platform and terms of the
technology honestly it doesn't matter
like right now we recording off a webcam
and I have a Yeti microphone I filmed
off my iPad off my phone off of a ten
thousand dollar camera off of my handy
cam I'll still make videos but here's an
example I I got I won't say the name I
got hired by a company to be on their TV
series and and they flew me out to their
offices on the west coast and they had
this huge production with a co-host and
like eight to ten people on set with
lights and cameras and sound and like
like trick that to the max like you know
they're spending tons of money they're
hiring me to come out there and do this
thing and then while I'm there I'm
taking my Sony Handycam
and and walking through the streets of
the city do my own videos for my YouTube
channel and in just one of my videos got
more views than then all of the like
miniseries that we did on the interviews
on their Channel yeah and so like I feel
like it's such as they wasted so much
money on this but they can I don't know
how they justify they justify it somehow
but it's not about the gear and so many
people asked me like what you to use
this yeah don't get don't get tricked up
in the gear much more as you like you
put Phoebe on something with a crappy
like five-year-old iPhone and she's
gonna crush it compared to some you know
rookie who's got all the fancy gear in
the world and so much more important
like it's easy to focus on that because
because that's easy to focus on like
yeah it's easy to think that hey I just
get that camera that's gonna make the
difference I don't want to put in all
the hard work about to make myself
better and improving my skills as a host
or a thought leader or an interviewer so
yeah like there's no single piece of
yeah yeah I know absolutely absolutely
true all right this is gonna be a tough
one but just name one
book documentary blog podcast or
internet TV channel that you'd like to
recommend to the community you know I
just made a list I just put on a video
of my seven favorite YouTube channels
for entrepreneurs and I put my own
channels number one mostly I think
because of the like I collect I a great
famous entrepreneurs and innovators and
thought leaders and and put out their
wisdom and so like even if you don't
like what I have to say we collect this
data from instead of watching 40 hours
of Elon Musk videos here it is his best
best stuff that he's ever said in eight
minutes for you to hear so I think it's
I'm a big fan of my own channel but if I
have to pick another one the one that I
like most there's two I would go with
gary vaynerchuk's channel he's on the
marketing side of things he's very
aggressive and can come off as rude and
you know swears a lot but if you can get
past that the message he has is a really
good one and the other ones Louis House
who has another YouTube channel I'm more
known as a podcaster so when a familiar
than school of greatness but also has a
YouTube channel that has video of his
podcast and he interviews you know
world-class performers in athletics and
authors and entrepreneurship and has
them on his show at least once a week
maybe twice a week and so those two
those two guys I watch every video
pretty much that they put out and I
would recommend checking it as we start
to wind down its expert predictions time
the year is 2025 so from your vantage
point in particular you know building
this internet TV channel that you didn't
expect to be making money off of but
it's come you know into a nice business
for you tell us what you think the
landscape will look like and what's one
piece of parting advice to build a
competitive advantage about nine years
out Phoebe it's the questions
I would say you want to be paying
attention to where people's attention is
and I think people been really slow to
adapt to it especially the bigger
companies I think even now the the
influencers the people with popular
YouTube channels are reaching more
people than in a lot of traditional
media and the advertisers still haven't
figured it out and a lot of the money's
still just gonna come in and so paying
attention to where people's attention is
and is going is super important it may
not always be YouTube you know it may be
SMAP tube that comes out and like that's
the thing right or snapchat is the thing
yeah right and so understanding where
people's attention are is and then
bringing it especially if you have a
skill like in the early days of YouTube
people sucked and still people now the
people who are asking people who are
doing interviews and podcasts a lot of
them suck like they don't have the
skills yet they're working on them but
they've just been podcasting for a year
where if you took your skills and your
abilities of like a decade or however
long you've been a journalist for asking
questions you could destroy in the
industry and they're not and so like all
these influencers who have grown up in
prominence are they're just because
people there's this huge demand and the
people with the most talent people who
already are already on already are sorry
on-air personalities they could be just
crushing it and so just be thinking
about paying attention to where people's
eyeballs are and then trying to keep
going there and as we close out you know
adding to that circling back brand
journalism community to where we were in
the beginning which is talking about not
just dreaming but actually taking action
and then of course Evans favorite word
and mine to actually believe right it's
all possible it's all possible and you
know if you think about it you know like
I have guests on the show when I ask
them that question about 2025 I can't
remember which episode it was but
gentleman said yeah it's they're gonna
technology will be implanted in us and I
mean it's it's wild the stuff that's
coming out so for me you know there's
people who will be afraid of all of this
and afraid like they want to keep it the
same you know and you have to like you
said learn and push forward and continue
to develop and persevere so I just thank
you so much I love what you're doing I'm
definitely a fan of your channel as well
so thank you so much Evan for being on
the brand journalism Advantage podcast
oh thank you having a fuse been fun well
that was fun yeah okay cool so okay do
you have any like clothes out that you
want so I actually well it we add in a
clothes at the end okay so we roll in
some music and stuff like that and yeah
I don't know how you want to do that I'm
happy to share that with you but
actually what I asked my guests to do is
to introduce the show so in the way the
guest does that it says their name what
we're talking about so we're talking
about building your internet TV channel
and you're listening to the brand
journalism advantage so you know I'm
Evan Carmichael however you want to
introduce yourself we're talking about
building your internet TV channel and
you're listening to the brand journalism
advantage so if you could do that for me
that'd be awesome
let me say entrepreneur and youtuber yet
and you're listening to the brand
journalism advantage the brand
journalism journalism advantage just
before that I would say what we're
talking about so I'm Evan Carmichael
youtuber and you know ha ha ha
entrepreneur we're talking about
building your internet TV channel and
you're listening to so you close with
and you're listening to a brand
journalism advantage cool we got people
watching live like is this still
supposed to be live yes is it still
supposed to live okay you're in behind
this is my
happens behind the scenes on a broadcast
that's right video podcast edition okay
alright so let me read it first
hi Evan Carmichael entrepreneur and
youtuber today we're talking about
building your internet TV channel and
you're listening to the brand journalism
advantage you got it okay
let me do that with a little more oomph
yeah okay hi I'm Evan Carmichael
entrepreneur and youtuber today we're
talking about building your internet TV
channel and you're listening to the
brain journalism advantage hey I didn't
hear your name
didn't I say hi Evan Carmichael I don't
know you can ask people listening but I
didn't hear it so maybe uh maybe do that
one more time alright again hi I'm Evan
Carmichael entrepreneur and youtuber
today we're talking about building your
internet TV channel and you're listening
to the brand journalism advantage boom
love it so so good Evan that was fun and
I really appreciate you being on the
show
cool do you want to get to some of the
comments of course of course
cool Andrews talking about having a
great wine we saw it back to like the
regret comment I think yeah do you have
a great why that's the foundation for
your otherwise is this a statement
question yeah well just like what's your
great why so you have a great wide that
is the foundation for your otherwise
like one big one this is above the
others yeah and the little baby why's
underneath yeah so uh-huh you know I I
do so I am all about the story um for me
I I became a you know people become
journalists for different reasons but I
really felt that I wanted a front seat
to the world right to be able to tell
those stories
so my why is always about getting the
story out and today as a brand
journalist in working for corporations
in helping other people build
what's so important to them it's gone
beyond just telling the story but
helping them live what I would call
purposeful lives and you know these
integrity of doing and pursuing what you
want and that's what drives me to do
what I do that's why I have you know
some 350 episodes of the brand
journalism advantage podcast because I'm
learning from that but then I also feel
like hey I could have done this and
called up and gotten these interviews
and just kept it to myself
but I felt like it's so important to get
it out to the world as well so that's
that's kind of in what's driven me and
it's the stories have changed I don't I
don't cover double homicides anymore
thankfully you know I now get to cover
the cool stuff like people like yourself
and and you know the editor in chief of
entrepreneurs gonna be on my show so
people like that who are really doing
awesome stuff and that's what inspires
me and that's that's what literally when
I feel those moments where I want to
give up that's what keeps me going
people people love the baby wise comment
they're hash tagging baby hog
storytellers hashtag baby wise J rise is
asking why is it called the branch or
lism advantage good question and
sometimes I wonder if I should have
called it that but but you know here's
kind of a shout-out to John Lee Dumas
who does entrepreneur on fire I met with
him and I actually told his story a
video story and we got into this
discussion about brand journalism and he
kind of advised me just call it what it
is and so in that moment I was like well
this brand journalism and it gives you a
competitive advantage so if you put it
all together that's why at the end of
the show I always ask the question
what's your competitive advantage in
20-25 brand journalism is storytelling
for brands not necessarily about brands
but it's to benefit them and their
audience and so it's not content
marketing it literally is sort of a new
style storytelling and it gives you that
advantage in your marketplace so the
brand journalism advantage it's it's
super long but well there you have it go
well the follow-up was thank you for the
clarity and people have a lot of respect
for positive storytellers so
there you go how do you stay on top of
social trends collective conversations
and the flow of attention hmm
man okay so my iPad sitting here next to
me my Mac books are here my smartphone I
am on social media all the time I do a
lot of events so I'm asked to emcee a
lot of different things you know I just
did at the time of this recording the La
Costa Film Festival and you know had a
lot of the directors in there and
learning about their storytelling from a
cinematography angle but I keep on my
iPhone and and my Apple watch I keep
tons of content flowing to me and I read
all the time I watch all the time I am
an avid learner and I think you'll hear
that about most journalists they want to
learn learn learn it's you know it's
like this insatiable desire that we have
and so I'm always plugged into that
maybe sometimes to a fault
you know that I have to kind of like
okay let's chill out and and and have
those those moments so that's why I go
and I practice yoga and and I try to
unplug from it but I really consider it
my job I can't do a good job for my
clients and I do take on lots of clients
especially in the lifestyle space and
I'm expected to know you know I can't
know everything you know I mean I often
call myself a strategist rather than an
expert even though I asked you know
expert predictions but because we're
always learning and we're always honing
that craft so I've spent 20 years in
front of cameras and and you know
microphones and things like that but
there's always something I learned from
someone else so I think that if you keep
those streams alive and then I use
things I can tell you I use bundle post
I use HootSuite I use Apple News I use
Google News I use Twitter everything you
can imagine to bring that in and just
kind of go through it so I set aside a
portion of my day to really get that
that download and
and then I I try to stay up on
everything even the things that I'm
maybe not as you know as into I still
think it's important to know about and
that's that's a journalist perspective
for sure cool
well people saying good answer I like
the honesty thank you nice hash tag avid
learner so they're liking it maybe one
last question cuz in a week yeah
basically asking about on-air
interviewers how can people be better
on-air interviewers or what are you
seeing wrong with how people are
interviewing on there so here's what I'd
recommend I started out at KPBS which is
the public broadcast station now that's
radio but I want to be on TV and I got
my feet wet there and I worked for you
know a cable portion of the station for
the visually impaired and I just
practiced so much like Evan said you I
think you said 4,000 videos or something
like that you get better by doing that
is the only way so what I do is I carry
this I carry a secondary iPhone because
I teach iPhone storytelling and so
sometimes you know I'm plugged in on
this one and sometimes I'm using this
with camera gear attached and I'm
telling stories sometimes these stories
get on the air as far as I when I say on
the air I'm talking about your
non-traditional now YouTube but
sometimes they make it on the air on TV
new segments you know that kind of thing
as well the way you get better is to
force yourself to do it so if you want
to be a better writer write everyday
read everyday make it a practice same
thing with my yoga same thing with the
interviewing so get these people onto
your show start as small as you have to
start ask them you know I do a lot of
speaking for people because I'm happy to
help but you know that's that's what got
me off the ground but the the number one
tip is don't just do it review it okay
and I didn't mean it to sound that way
but it kind of came out that way you
know literally don't just do it review
it because when I started out in the
industry
I was a
to watch myself on camera because I was
just horrified I didn't think I looked
good I didn't like the way I sounded I
was super critical you know all of this
goes through your head you have to be
able to watch it and review it because
if you don't you're just basically doing
without evaluating so that's the same
thing as if you work for a brand or your
business and you go out and you put out
all this content and you never look to
see is anybody reading it or what's
happening with it or you don't measure
it you get better through measuring
results same when you hit the gym you
get better by knowing how much you
lifted last week versus how much you're
lifting this week right so that is
probably one of the things that I see
the least practiced and when I when I
coach in this area and I'm videotaped
folks often they don't want to watch it
you know they just want to hear me give
their feedback and I'll say or even
after a podcast you know what's really
great I've noticed a trend lately is the
putt the interviewee will say to me what
could I have done better so if you ask
that question that also helps but
literally go back and listen to it as
painful as it may be and a lot of times
you'll find it's not painful because it
really was indeed good the final part
that I would say to that is just be real
when I learned I started off talking
about KPBS when I learned to watch their
style if you listen to Ira Glass and you
you follow the great story too and that
those guys are really great storytellers
it's different from TV news because we
have a very commercialized structured
style which actually I love this YouTube
space and Facebook because I can break
away from that in a way that I couldn't
break away from it as a TV newscaster
because I had to hit certain times and
you know there's a countdown going on
five four three you got to hit this
soundbite right and there's all this
going on like you were talking about
with all the cameras and everything so
it's a different vibe so I think now is
the greatest time for some of the people
who are just super low-key they don't
have that singsong enos and their voice
that comes from you know a newscaster
that has been poorly trained or just you
know isn't plugged in so that last
parting advice after
reviewing it and being real is keeping
in your head who you're talking to and
being in the present moment because you
will go to somewhere else if you're not
in the present moment and when your
delivery isn't isn't in the present
moment
you're not gonna sound good you're gonna
sound canned or fake and people don't
resonate with that so now we can be as
real as we can be and that's what's
awesome I love that very cool
that's a fountain of wisdom over there
well Phoebe thank you so much for the
opportunity thank you guys for watching
on the live stream too and all the great
questions you can check Phoebe I that
think like a journalist comm this
podcast coming out in a couple weeks
yeah maybe even sooner I'm gonna link it
together with you know some of the
founders of our enough founders but the
managing editor and the editor-in-chief
of entrepreneur so good good stuff
cool well thank you guys again for
watching Phoebe and I both believe in
you we hope you continue to believe in
yourselves and whatever your one word is
much love guys see you soon bye bye